in den Kellern und auf den
Schrottplätzen dieser Welt lauern wahre
schätze ich will also mal wieder Sachen
die keiner mehr benutzt wieder
herrichten und dann auf Ebay für
möglichst viel Geld bei einer Auktion an
den Höchstbietenden verkaufen dieses
Video wird unterstützt von finanzguru
mehr dazu später überall der Stau keine
nichts anfassen wir setzen also das
gemacht haben war ich auf der Riesen
Schnitzeljagd auf der Suche nach Schrott
oder nach irgendwelche Sachen wie ein
bisschen herrichten können das haben wir
jetzt diesmal eigentlich auch vor gehabt
aber Manu meinte er hat noch ein paar
alte Sachen die gerade im Keller
verstorben und da sind richtige Schätze
dabei wir haben jetzt hier einmal zwei
Franzosen eine richtig geile Rohrzange
und als Hauptgewinn würde ich jetzt mal
sagen diesen absoluten heißen
Schraubstock der ja hier ein bisschen
also eigentlich kaum lang hat und noch
gut gekostet ist aber richtig gute
Qualität hat also wenn du hier wirklich
gar nichts und bevor ich das gute Stück
restaurieren kann muss ich erstmal in
seine Einzelteile zerlegen also gehen
wir mal rein und den Schlüssel ja das
geht sogar richtig gut das war ein Kilo
Rost draußen irgendwie in der Schraube
noch drin hängt
[Musik]
immer noch nicht was damit genau
erreicht hat wahrscheinlich kann man den
jetzt komplett raus drehen jetzt geht's
nicht mehr aber jetzt kann
das ist ja geil ja das ist ja sogar nur
ein Teil ist ein bisschen locker ich
weiß nicht was passieren muss damit ich
das hier raus kriegen
bisschen Gewalt Alter die Hände sind auf
jeden Fall am Start wenn man es mal ein
bisschen sauber macht sieht man an einer
Stelle dass da so eine Einlassung ist in
diesem Kreuzschlitz reinpassen würde gib
mir mal den Pass auf Alter
okay ja
natürlich auch geschmiert deswegen auch
ordentlich Fett dran weil wir das auch
neu erkennen werden muss das Ganze fährt
natürlich weg von mir jetzt mal nicht so
ganz professionelle fetter ist
Isopropanol aber das tut es auch
das löst es hoffentlich alles
[Musik]
sauber die Unterlage ist sehr dreckig
und jetzt muss im nächsten Schritt der
Lack und der raus hier weg und aber geht
in den Sandstrahler
im letzten ebay Video habe ich die
ganzen Sachen ja quasi mehr oder weniger
mit der Hand oder mit irgendwelchen
Werkzeugen geschliffen das dauert aber
ultra lang deswegen haben wir
mittlerweile in Sandstrahler der kriegt
noch ein paar andere Sachen hin und ein
paar andere Ecken kommt da noch rein
Aussehen geht auch schneller dann habe
ich jetzt hier mein Teil nach dem Deckel
auf und leg das mal rein ich habe jetzt
hier von außen zu Handschuhe dann hier
so eine Pistole und wenn ich da drauf
drückt dann kommt das andere raus und
mit den Sachen und dann raus runter
[Musik]
frisch aus dem Sandstrahler ist es
wunderschön
so zusammenbauen würde aber draußen
außerdem war der originale auch so ein
bisschen blau deswegen habe ich auch
übrigens zwei Lacke einmal einen
dunkelgrauen das ist auf Nummer aber
eher auch ein bisschen langweiliger oder
hier was blaues ja für Blau ein bisschen
schwierig mein Schraubstock hier den
finde ich eigentlich von der Farbe er
ultra hässlich das sieht aber eigentlich
ein bisschen cooler aus drum würde ich
sagen nehmen wir mal so ein altes Stück
Metall boah das sieht schon krass aus
das nehme ich auch immer gleich und
verstreicht einfach drauf und ey sie
muss ehrlich sagen für die Farbe jetzt
schon ultra geil auch das sehen wir auch
so deckend ist ja ich glaube das wird
ultra geil ich probiere die andere Farbe
ist gar nicht aus so jetzt das spaßigste
Teil das Lackieren Alter ist das Fallen
das ist schon Harz
[Musik]
richtig gut funktioniert sieht
wunderschön aus mega geil diese Farbe
hängt jetzt gerade hier im Hintergrund
hier ist schon die zweite ja die hängt
gerade die Schnur quasi im Innenleben
drin hängt das eh nicht gestrichen wird
also gibt's da keine hässlichen Spuren
und weiter geht's mit dem Bemalen
[Musik]
es sieht wunderschön aus krasse Farbe
kann man wirklich nicht anders sagen und
jetzt kommt zusammenbauen jetzt ist die
Frage ob die überhaupt noch zusammen
passen weil es ein bisschen Lack drauf
ich habe versucht das möglichst Smart zu
machen aber
gar kein Problem sieht jetzt einfach nur
wieder richtig schön aus wobei die
unlackierten Sachen jetzt erstmal ein
bisschen einölen wird einfach damit das
nicht so schnell Rost übrigens die
Schraube hier einmal ausgetauscht durch
eine die nicht also ich mache den mal
rein
wie diese wilde Feder und jetzt kommt
dieser türkische springen wieder drauf
und das ist drauf machen deutlich easy
ja sein sollte eigentlich muss man nur
drauf drücken
ja der ist drin den kann man gut drehen
weil das ist jetzt schön gefettet ist
die hier fettig auch noch so und dann
geht das jetzt hoffentlich rein fertig
es fehlen noch die Schraube so der ist
fertig let's go jetzt machen
so sieht der fertige Schraubstock im
Mini Fotostudio aus dass ich kurzerhand
gezimmert habe und indem ich jetzt
einige möglichst ästhetische
Produktfotos macht diese nämlich für den
Verkauf mit das Wichtigste und nachdem
auf Ebay ein Produktname und eine
Produktkategorie gewählt wurde werden
auch diese Fotos da reingestellt sowie
die Spannbreite und Spannweite des
Schraubstocks ebay schlägt hier bei
unserem Produkt für die Auktion
64,77 € statt bereits vor aber wir
machen volles Risiko um maximale
Aufmerksamkeit anzuziehen und stellen
als Mindestangebot nur 1 € ein wenn ich
Pech habe ist also die ganze Arbeit
umsonst und jemand bekommt den
Schraubstock fast geschenkt aber ich
glaube der Schraubstock geht weg wie nix
egal ob man sein Geld jetzt wie wir das
versuchen durchs verkaufen auf eBay
verdient oder mit dem richtigen Job den
Überblick über seine Einnahmen aber vor
allem seine Ausgaben zu behalten kann
ganz schön tricky sein mit der App
finanzguru dem Sponser des heutigen
Videos ist das anders da erhalte der
automatisch ein perfekten Überblick über
eure Finanzen egal ob Girokonto
Kreditkarte Depot oder Börse alles kann
eingebunden werden und eure Einnahmen
und Ausgaben werden automatisch
kategorisiert und übersichtlich in der
App aufbereitet wenn euch dadurch dann
z.B auffällt dass er noch dieses eine
Abo habt dass er schon lange kündigen
wolltet kein Problem ein Fingertip und
FinanzBuch kündigt den Vertrag einfach
für euch
komplett rechtssicher also holt euch
jetzt kostenlos über den Link in der
Videobeschreibung finanzguru und löst
den Code tomory im Reiter mehr ein
um kostenlos finanzguru+ für ganze drei
Monate statt der üblichen 7 Tage zu
testen und erhaltet einen noch tieferen
Einblick in eure Finanzen mit
ausführlichen Analysen smarten
budgetvorschlägen Excel-Export und eine
Anzeige eures frei verfügbaren
Einkommens bis zum nächsten
Gehaltseingang unser nächster
Gehaltseingang ist hoffentlich von Ebay
also weiter geht's wir sind jetzt sechs
Stunden auf Ebay online und ich schau
mal ob schon wo wurde reingekommen sind
uh wir haben zwei Euro auf die auf die
Schraubzwinge nice also schon zwei
Gebote der erste
Neugeborenes gibt 10 Beobachter und 17
Aufrufe ich glaube aber tatsächlich das
dann noch viel viel mehr geht Optionen
werden immer am Ende erst so richtig
spannend ich glaube wir könnten sogar
auf 100 € kommen das Geld was bei den
Verkäufen rausbringen bekommt übrigens
natürlich Manu der hat ja die Werkzeuge
schließlich auch in seinem Keller
gefunden und der restauriert jetzt auch
den nächsten Gegenstand Felix sorry
Mikrofon ins Inflation ich versuch's
laut zu reden dass ich es nicht gerade
so kacke anhört ich weiß nicht was ich
sagen soll Thomas meint ja ja
hier noch mal da
unser neues
unsere neue Sandstrahlkabine brauchen
jetzt nur Druckluft kommt
ich fange an mit dem bin ich mal
gespannt weil der ist hier fest relativ
fest muss schauen was da so abgeht
klicken wir jetzt hier rein ich hole mir
auf jeden Fall Staubmaske und LG
Gehörschutz
[Musik]
es funktioniert so gut schaut so geil
aus wie neu weiter
also ich habe den jetzt schon mal so
weit Sand gestartet dass er echt gut
aussieht jetzt habe ich gesehen jetzt
hier eine Schraube drin das mache ich
den mal auf weil er klemmt immer noch
ich kriege immer noch nicht auf dem Zug
und ich denke wenn ich die Schraube hier
aufmacht kann ich ihn komplett
auseinander bauen und dann komplett
sauber machen den Stellen wo ich jetzt
nicht hingekommen bin
und jetzt sollten
[Musik]
einfach das geile also alten Werkzeug
man kann es komplett zerlegen und wieder
reparieren
[Musik]
[Applaus]
funktioniert einfach wie neu erzählen
die das gewesen
so den kleinen Franzosen Engländer
variabler Schrauben
Maulschlüssel habe ich gesandstrahlt
aber der ist fest also der geht nicht
auf ich werde den jetzt mit Rostlöser
einsprühen und dann wieder hoffentlich
wieder
[Musik]
ich probier mal vorsichtig ob ich dieses
Teil zum Drehen bekommen das ist so fest
dreht sich minimal ich weiß jetzt auch
nicht wo das so fest ist
wird besser
und mach's heiß und dann geht's
hoffentlich auf
[Musik]
[Applaus]
rostiges Ding das geht es auch ab in die
Sandstrahlkabine hier seht ihr ein
Vorher Nachher vom kleinen
rollgalschlüssel den übrigens nicht
lackieren der Ross ist auf jeden Fall
komplett weg und hier seht ihr jetzt den
vorher nachher Vergleich vom großen
rollgabelschlüssel und den werden wir
auch wieder nicht lackieren und da ist
der Rost auch wieder komplett weg
nachdem wir auch davon nette Fotos
gemacht haben geht's damit wieder ab auf
Ebay 24 Stunden ist der Schraubstock
jetzt hier auf ebay drin und wir sind
bei 20 € 50 ja das klingt richtig ab wir
haben schon sechs Gebote die haben sich
hier auf 10 € 12,20 € und jetzt eben
20,50 hochgeboten richtig was und ich
glaube es geht auch noch locker auf 100
€ würde ich jetzt mal schätzen weil es
einfach noch ganze zwei Tage läuft die
sechs verschiedenen Bieter von in die
sechs verschiedenen Gebote kommen die
werden sie auch noch richtig hoch bieten
würde ich mal sagen die beiden Franzosen
hier auf ebay sind immer noch bei einem
Euro oder geht überhaupt gar nichts
vielleicht ist das ja bei der ein
bisschen besser und weiter geht's mit
der Rohrzange wenn ich hier die Mutter
ganz runter machen ich glaube da kann
ich die auch auseinander nehmen wird
auch gut
[Musik]
wenn man sich jetzt mal anschaut was das
vorher für ein rostiger Haufen war und
wie sehr das jetzt wieder in neuem Glanz
erstrahlt dann ist das einfach ein
geiles Gefühl dass wir das erstens in
ein bis zwei Tagen inklusive Lack
Trocknungszeit hingekriegt haben und
dass wir zweitens den ganzen Zeug jetzt
noch mal ein neues Leben eingehaucht
haben
direkt nach kürzester Zeit ihr erstes
Gebot von einem Euro 24 Stunden später
hängt die allerdings immer noch einmal
bei einem Euro finde ein bisschen schade
bin ich ein bisschen enttäuscht weil ich
finde die echt geil und für 1 € will man
ja nicht wirklich weggeben ne aber das
ist jetzt ungefähr zwei Tage online ein
Tag gibt's noch und uh der Schraubstock
einfach bei 57 € oder das ist heftig und
vor allem da geht noch richtig was genau
16 Stunden in den letzten Stunden
passiert da das meiste ich glaube 400 €
knacken wir wirklich noch das werde ich
cool die anderen Sachen sind alle immer
noch bei einem Euro einfach wir
mittlerweile aber auch für den Franzosen
Angebote aber der hier ja moin also der
geht gar nicht weg die Option geht jetzt
nicht mehr lang ja die ist gleich vorbei
und die Schraubzwingen ist bei 60 € und
die läuft noch 15 Minuten nur okay krass
ich dachte wir wären schon weiter
mittlerweile aber die Situation spitzt
sicher wie bekannt am Ende hinzu hier
wird sie ordentlich hochgeboten der
Kollege hier ist mittlerweile bei 3,50 €
und die anderen beiden inklusive dem
hier bei dem Euro und das ist schon sehr
enttäuschend bisher aber vielleicht
kommt er in den letzten 15 Minuten noch
mal rein so 3/4 Stunde später
unterschraubung ist für 59 Euro ist
geblieben ging nicht auf 100 wie ich
erhofft hatte aber 60 Euro ist auf jeden
Fall stark würde ich sagen es ist ein
sehr sehr geiler Schraubstock deswegen
würde ich sagen dass da noch mehr wert
gewesen wäre definitiv aber das teuerste
was man beim letzten restaurationsvideo
auf Ebay gekriegt haben war halt diese
Blechschere für 6 € deswegen finde ich
das schon mal überhaupt nicht schlecht
am Verlauf der Gebote erkennt man jetzt
dass es tatsächlich die ersten beiden
Tage relativ exponentiell nach oben ging
aber am dritten Tag so gut wie nichts
passiert ist mittlerweile sind alle
Aktion durch Schraubstock hier eben 60 €
finde mit Sicherheit eine sehr sehr
glücklichen neuen Besitzer der
rollgabelschlüssel hier der ist auch
richtig geil richtig fett massives geh
für 5 € Weg tut mir ehrlich gesagt auch
ein bisschen weh schönes Teil aber da
freuen sich der neue Besitzer mit
Sicherheit auch ja und die letzten
beiden Sachen also dass das Ding hier
für 1 € wegging ja ist okay ja also das
kann ich verkraften aber wer auch immer
dieses Teil für 1 € gesnackt hat das ist
der wahre Gewinner an diesem Video ja
auf jeden Fall ultra Geld gespart weil
er sich hier was gebraucht hat wenn ihr
jetzt übrigens auch viel Geld sparen
wollt checkt die App FinanzBuch aus
überlegen in der Beschreibung da kriegt
er richtig guten Überblick wo er Geld
hingehen und für was und ich hoffe euch
hat das Video gefallen ich finde vorher
nachher Vergleich ist heftig und hat
Spaß gemacht also